ladies and gentlemen welcome to the tim
dillon show adjusting to taliban rule
uh
in afghanistan clarissa ward the
journalist
who uh famously
uh called the taliban friendly which
everyone got mad about
but they were being friendly they were
chanting death to america
but they were chanting in a fun way
and then all the people jumped on her
they were like oh cnn will describe any
of america's enemies as friendly it's
like hey
you know they were they were
they were they were ebullient they were
happy they had won
there's no reason for them to not be
friendly they won the taliban won
all these people that are like no we
didn't really win they won
what do you call it we we we
we were thrown out of the country
you know they threw us out they waited
20 years of painstaking
taking these little towns and villages
that nobody gave a [ __ ] about
building their power base back 20 years
fighting for afghanistan
and they finally did it and they're
thrilled
they're very happy which is why as
they're chanting death to america
there's something uh
they're friendly there there's a
happiness but clarissa ward
uh finally left the country she was able
to leave on a
an evacuation flight these flights at
the afghan airport i mean this airport i
mean it's worse than laguardia
[Music]
that's how bad it is over there i mean
it's really bad
and um
everyone's
saying that we should
this isn't the one you pay for
but
this guy now this is said a 19 year old
afghan footballer this is like tragic
was among those who fell from a usc 17
military aircraft
after rescuing people from taliban ruled
region
this is the tragedy
of
this type of event when there's a coup
um and you see it here and i don't know
if you can see that but you see bodies
falling from the plane
and it's [ __ ] heartbreaking
that this is what happened when you have
that general that [ __ ]
uh millie i think it's his name who's
going i saw no indication that yeah i
had no idea we had we saw nothing there
was no indication that the taliban was
taking over we had no idea this was
gonna happen
this is the same guy that gave that
speech a couple of months ago where he's
like i want to learn why white people
hate
remember that
that guy who was sitting there like he
was uh doing a uh a monologue
you know from a new uh you know shonda
rhimes project on netflix he was like i
wanna learn why white people hate
i wanna know
well how about you find out
why the [ __ ] country
was taken over by the taliban isn't that
your job
shouldn't you devote at least as much
time
to finding out
why afghanistan is failing miserably
as you do to wanting to find out why
white people hate
your words
um
and this is you know america has no
credibility now and by the way it really
didn't have a ton of credibility leading
into this last couple of years
but now we have none like imagine going
into a country now
with a straight face and telling them
like we take care of our people
don't worry about it we take care of our
people
if you work for us you help us if you're
a translator
if uh you help us gather intelligence
when [ __ ] hits the fan we've got your
back
we don't leave people
i mean there's video evidence
there is you can you could like anyone
they're telling that to should just pull
up a youtube link and be like actually
what about this
you have this young good-looking
19-year-old football
player whose entire life is over
because he trusted
the united states
that is what's tragic about it this
guy's entire life is over because he
trusted the united states a member of
afghanistan's national youth soccer team
was among the people who were killed as
they tried desperately to cling to a u.s
military plane evacuating people from
kabul
uh he was 17 this guy
jeez i thought some say 19 some say 17.
uh monday a crowd of afghans surged on
the tarmac of the international airport
in the frantic scramble to escape a
country newly overrun by the taliban
anwari was one of hundreds of people who
wanted to leave the country and in an
incident fell off an american military
plane and died
the sports community of afghanistan was
in grief
the statement said it wished zaki a
place in heaven and offered a prayer
that god grant i mean this is so [ __ ]
sad
and this is unfortunately
what happens when you trust the united
states of america i mean
there's no other way to say it
i feel horrible for him
now i'm going to be a bit
i'm going to be
a little
and i
i might it may come off as insensitive
not about him
but i i may
this may
read a bit callous
i'm
less
concerned
with the people who went there to do
charity now here's why
this is real charity
most people when they do charity they
like write a check
and they go to some event
uh you know in manhattan or bel air they
go to somebody's mansion and they buy a
50 000 dress and they write a 25 000
check
and they it is a social event charity
true philanthropy in cities like new
york and places like l.a is how you rise
up the latter of
uh the social scene in that city
this is not that this is real
charity
real
life you are putting yourself in danger
you're putting yourself at risk
to help people
nothing wrong with that but
here we go
when things go wrong as they have
this is when charity becomes even more
real this no longer is a feel-good
mission
afghanistan's no longer a place for
white women to go find themselves
and just connect and feel and like i
just want to get away
from san francisco for a while i just
want to go no no no you're in it now
you are now
living in afghanistan and
listen
some charity most charity i would
imagine is good people great people per
se
helping other people but there is some
charity that's a little cynical
there is some charity
where it's white people
who want to like show the world that
they're a little different
and they care
even though do they
and not always white people but
primarily web and then they go to places
like afghanistan and they do like you
know whatever whatever they're doing you
know you know they they distribute
um you know ipads to to the women and
let them listen to call her daddy well
that is now over
that is now over caller daddy has been
banned in afghanistan the soho house
kabul is closed
okay so now yes i mean ann coulter said
everyone's like all these americans got
to get
evacuated from kabul she goes who the
hell
is in kabul
but listen there are people there there
are good people there no doubt
there are people there
who went to that country to genuinely
help women
and people but then there are people
there
who
we're cynically exploiting a situation
and this happens all the time and some
of these um
charities are cia front groups we know
that
knowingly or unknowingly and they know
um
and some people are there
to genuinely help and some people are
there because it's uh
you know it's maybe more about them and
it's more about
their you know i've talked to people and
i'm not just talking here everyone goes
you're just talking
with your fat mouth no i have spoken to
people that have gone to these countries
under the guise of being a savior of
helping people and you know what some of
them and i'm not speaking about only the
military although i have spoken to
members of the military but i'm talking
about people that have worked in the
capacity
of charity and you know what some of
them have told me
some of them have said
you know going there and helping i
realized that the
the people of the country
did not want me there
and this is a hard lesson to learn but
it is a lesson to learn they go
we were not culturally in sync
yes there were things i did that helped
them they were grateful for certain
things but overall
on the whole
it was um
you know
i don't want to say a wasted effort
but it was
perhaps a little in vain because some of
it is vanity
some of it is it's why i didn't go over
to afghanistan
and start
teaching women to read
now people say to me
well that sounds like
uh you're uh you don't care i
care
the problem is
that you're fighting against
the ocean and the ocean is always going
to win the waves are going to win
they're going to knock you back down
and
[Music]
i believe there's a lot of charity to be
done in america i know i don't know how
i got that idea
but i'm telling you if you take a road
trip
through america you're gonna be
convinced as i am that there are tons of
people to help right here does it mean
that you shouldn't help people over
there but there's a lot of people to be
helped right here but that's not as
glamorous let's be honest that's not as
sexy to tell your friends that you went
to vassar with that you're helping
people in ohio you want to tell them
that you're helping people in kabul
let's be very honest and today
is when you have to pay the piper you
have to really be the thing that you
want to be truly
if you really want to be
the person who's like yeah i'm in kabul
right now
like teaching people how to rad
well today's the day that that just
became real
that's all you may have to join the
resistance
i want to read this thread this is a
great thread we did a great episode on
the patreon about this
uh because this
this era
which spanned 20 years it my awakening
into uh u.s foreign policy
um
maybe happened
in the most
meaningful way
with the onset of the afghanistan war
because i was in 11th grade and all of a
sudden things mattered in a way they
hadn't before
friends of mine their parents died in 9
11. friends of mine were joining the
military and were becoming marines and
things like that
the onset of the afghan war was when our
country's foreign policy was more than
something that
i looked at
in um
you know a theoretical way this became
real and um i when i was 17 and addicted
to cocaine i thought it was a great idea
i thought all this because i was very
face value and when i read a tom
friedman article in the new york times
and he was like the world has gone from
interconnected to hyper connect you know
all these things that mean nothing but
you're like yeah i'm smart
i'm smart
and then tom friedman would write an
article where he'd go you know i saw a
kid in an osama bin laden shirt and a
yankees cap and we need to make sure he
grows into the cap and i'd go yeah
yeah that's something he wrote and i'd
go yeah that's smart that's smart and i
believed you know that if we went around
the world and helped free these people
um
they would love us again i i was i was
on cocaine
i had an excuse i was a 17 year old
closeted cocaine addict from long island
whose emotions were completely out of
whack with his thoughts
i was just feeling things and not
thinking
i remember just going yeah like you'd
sit on the bus and you'd watch them that
was like the era of like patriotic
montages and you know the concert for 9
11 and you know bruce springsteen and
the who and all these people and
you know it was a it was a big thing and
it was a beautiful moment for the
country because we had just attacked
ourselves
and then after that we had you know we
launched into this very kind of
beautiful
campaign of of healing and you know
patriotism and but it felt good and it
felt like this is right and i remember i
wanted to join the military i thought
about it i was looking one day in the
library you know i like never went to
class i was in study hall in the library
looking at like requirements to join the
cia because
when you're young and something like
that happens you go
i want to live a life of meaning and
purpose and look at these dumb teachers
they don't [ __ ] do anything and
all these entertainers and celebrities
and you know all this fame and money the
two things now i've realized are the
only things that matter but back then i
thought that what really mattered was
honor and valor and serving a purpose
higher than yourself god was i wrong but
i thought for a moment a brief moment
right after that happened that actually
life was about helping other people it
was about agreeing that certain things
were right and certain things were wrong
and going to the places where wrong was
being done and reversing it and making
it right making the world a better place
that's what i genuinely believed on
cocaine in the library of my high school
and i would uh you know say how do i get
into the fbi how do i go uh and frame
people how do i get into the cia how do
i blackmail doctors to not give kids
medicine so that we can figure out a way
for exxon mobil to do more efficient
business i didn't know
you see i thought the cia was like a
crack squad of people that were like
there's the bomb on that bus they're
gonna kill babies and the cia would like
jump through the windows of the bus and
get the bomb and then like throw it in
the field and it would blow up and then
the bus driver would be like and he'd be
an old black man not because he's racist
because my bus driver keith who i loved
was an old black man and he'd be like
thank you
and he would just drive the kids to the
school that's what i thought was
happening but i was so wrong about that
i come to find out after many years of
reading books and rehab i found out that
i was wrong
i was wrong i started to get control of
my emotions get control of what was
going on but for a while there i didn't
i was just sitting in the library
with holy trinity high school
drugged up stoned or coked out and
eating some really good meatball parm
chicken parm lunches phenomenal really
good especially for high school but
really for anywhere
and uh and then friday bacon
cheeseburger day and then you would just
be stoned and eat and then you would
just kind of stare at the computer and
you would just go i want to live a life
of meaning and intrigue and purpose
and i i didn't know anything and i
remember i had friends of mine that
became
uh marines i had friends of mine that
went
uh into the service
and some of them served multiple tours
and i
i visited uh a few of them like you know
down in north carolina camp lejeune
and i um
my voice is starting to go i got to be
careful i did a show last night at the
vulcan gas company in austin it was a
lot of fun but everybody was smoking in
the green room and it was like it gets
my throat and i haven't smoked in two
months
so now this was somebody who i believed
served they did serve they were deployed
there twice once in 2018 once in 2009 or
10. this is
uh as painful and brutal an assessment
as you can read
looking at all the life lost
uh which is more important but also the
amount of money spent the resources
diverted to this
uh engagement
um
which again we know the cynical
uh outlook we covered on the patreon you
know the chaos
the pentagon losing all this money
uh the the rare earth minerals that are
under afghanistan the pipeline deals the
[ __ ]
um poppy fields we get it all we don't
know the full extent of the pillaging
and the things that happened
and we won't know the full extent of
that uh probably for years or until some
real investigative journalism is done
but this
uh thread this screed really sat with me
because i was like god it's tough to to
read this
at knowing what we know now but it says
boy howdy am i having a lot of feelings
about afghanistan today i was deployed
there twice
once in 2008 and once and once in 2009
10.
it was already obvious that the taliban
would sweep through the very instant we
left and here we are today
i know how bad the taliban is i know
what they do to women and little boys
i i know what they're going to do to the
interpreters and the people who
cooperated with it's awful it's bad but
we are leaving and all i feel is grim
relief
afghanistan is a dusty beige nightmare
of a place full of proud brave people
who did not want us [ __ ] there and we
called them hajis and worse and they
were better than we were braver and
stronger and smarter i remember going
through the phones of the people we
detained and finding clip after clip of
bollywood musicals women singing in
fields of flowers rarely did i find
anything incriminating i remember
finding propaganda footage cut together
from the soviet invasion and our own
operation enduring uh enduring whatever
and laughing about how stupid afghans
were not to know that we weren't the
russians and eventually i started
realizing i was the stupid one
i remember how every year the u.s would
have to decided to deal with the opium
fields you could let them alone and then
the taliban would shake the farmers down
and use the money to buy weapons or you
could carpet bomb the fields and then
the farmers would join the taliban
or you could give the farmer's
fertilizer as an incentive to grow wheat
instead of opium poppy and the farmers
would sell the fertilizer to the taliban
who used it to make explosives for ieds
that could destroy a million-dollar
mrap whatever it is and maim everyone
inside i remember we weren't allowed to
throw batteries away because people who
worked on base would go through the
trash and collect hundreds of dead
batteries wired them together so that
they just had enough juice for one
charge and that charge to detonate an
ied
i remember the look on my roommate's
face after she got back from cutting the
dead bodies of two soldiers out of a
humvee that got blown up by an ied and i
have always imagined uh that was made
with fertilizer from an opium farmer and
detonated with a hundred thrown out
batteries
i remember an afghan kid who worked in
the dfac cafeteria who we called cowboy
always wore this cowboy hat and an i'm a
stupid t-shirt someone had given him
always with a big smile high school age
cowboy was a good student and he wanted
to go to college in america but they
weren't colleges that took afghans the
education system was was too [ __ ] no
program to help kids like him i looked i
wonder if he's dead now for serving his
food and dreaming of something different
but a cowboy is dead then he died a long
time ago and if cowboy is dead then it's
our fault for going in there in the
first place giving his family the option
of trusting us when we are the least
trustworthy people on the planet
we use people up and throw them away
like it's nothing and now we're leaving
and the predictable thing is happening
the taliban is surging in and taking it
all back
they have what you can't buy or train
they have patience and a bloody
mindedness that warrants more respect
than we ever gave them
i am team get the [ __ ] out of
afghanistan which is a friend pointed
out to me today has always been team
taliban
it's team taliban or team stay forever
there is no third team so i'm sitting
here reading these sad [ __ ] tweets
about the suffering in afghanistan and
the horror of the encroaching taliban
and how awful it is that this is
happening but i can't stop feeling this
grim happiness like finally you [ __ ]
finally you get to see it too no more
blown up soldiers no more bollywood
videos on phones whose owners are
getting shipped to god knows where no
more hypocrisy no more pretending it
meant anything it didn't it didn't mean
a [ __ ] thing wow
what a thread
and it is crazy but if you remember the
beginning of the afghan war we were just
sweeping people up some of them
terrorists some of them not
and sending them to places like
guantanamo bay sending them to bagram
which i believe is in afghanistan it
might have been in iraq sending them the
places to i think it was in afghanistan
bagram air force base uh it's
afghanistan yes sending them to places
like the salt pit to be tortured look
that up look up the salt
the bagram salt
yeah
the salt plate was a black prison
okay meaning that it was a cia black
site for interrogation it's located
north of kabul and was the location of a
brick factory prior to the afghanistan
war that's where we would bring people
and torture them
because we were there to help them
you see
we were there to help them and we would
bring them to this uh underground prison
this brick factory here and torture them
mercilessly
until they gave us some type of
information um and people were tortured
to death and died there and how do you
think that made the people in
afghanistan feel do you think we lost a
few hearts and minds with that with the
salt pit
do you think perhaps
yeah ex u.s detainees describe
unreported c.i.a torture
you know i mean it's like jesus electric
chair threats guys yeah water torture
waterboarding beatings
with electric care they would put people
in boxes and put bugs in there let them
crawl on them i mean this was again
this was how we were going to break the
spirit of these people well guess what
it didn't work
didn't work we lost this one and we lost
and there's there's no other way to yes
we could drop a bombs and nukes or
whatever but we lost the ground game
here big time we didn't have the will
nor should we have the will we're
fighting for afghanistan
um
and this sucks
it sucks across the board it sucks for
the afghans that thought they were gonna
have a different life it sucks for the
soldiers who died and their deaths
don't don't mean anything it sucks for
the people that went over there to do
some charity
that sucks
if you're still there it's you know it
really is gonna test how much
you believe i mean you know
show
the afghan airport show that plane
leaving okay
this is a very
this is a crazy
scene to watch you see this c-17
this is a wild video to watch if you
haven't seen it which i'm sure you have
and i'm telling you right now
uh
there's a few days here before as i said
on the patreon we're gonna get a media
blackout and once there's a media
blackout it's pretty much
you know
we're pretty much done
no one's gonna care anymore so now that
look at this
okay ben this is the wrong video this is
the scene of austin texas this is a
scene
of people leaving austin texas look at
this
they're all leaving
look at this scene of people running
down south congress to get out of austin
texas to go back to a real city
that's the austin airport
there's all the comics that moved here
they thought they were gonna be on joe
rogan's show every week
they're gonna comics are gonna leave
austin like afghani translators that
worked with the department of defense
they are going to get on planes so
quickly and get the [ __ ] out of there
because they all thought they were
coming down here to do rogan's show
you know
and then he had some guy that he like
hunted for bigfoot with on the ninth for
the ninth time
and all these comics are sitting here in
austin going wait a minute when's my
time
you better cling to that plane
and get out
leaving your house is whatever
i like doordash a little help from
doordash you can get dinner household
essentials and everything on your
grocery list delivered ever pulled to
the driveway after a trip to the grocery
store only to realize you forgot that
one key ingredient for dinner now you
have options get the groceries you need
or a backup meal from your favorite
local restaurant delivered with doordash
so they will they will deliver you
groceries food everything they'll
connect you with everything you want
it's time to get back out there but if
you're not quite ready for a full-blown
adventure there's still ways to explore
the world from the comfort of your home
door dash has got 300 000 partners you
can support your neighborhood's go-to's
or choose from favorite national
restaurants like popeyes chipotle and
the cheesecake factory ordering is easy
all your items will be safely left
outside your door when you choose
contactless delivery drop off
for a limited time tim dillon show
listeners can get 25 off and zero
delivery fees on their first order of 15
or more think about that 25 off zero
or more when you download the
doordarshan and enter code tim dillon
25 off up to 10 value zero delivery fees
on the first order when you download the
doordarshan in the app store and enter
code tim dillon do it right now
that's tim dillon for 25
off your first order with doordash
think about that you got to do it it
makes a lot of sense
bespoke post we all want things we all
love surprises
bespoke post only sends guys the best
stuff every month no matter what you're
into
box of awesome as you cover it from
breezy summer styles to grooming goods
to travel and outdoor gear box of
awesome has collections for every part
of your life to get started take the
quiz at box of awesome.com your answers
will help them pick the right box of
awesome for you they release new boxes
every month across a ton of different
categories it's free to sign up and you
can skip a month or cancel any time each
box costs only 45 dollars but has over
70 worth of gear inside so you just get
a box every month of really cool stuff
once you take this quiz and they figure
out what you like
twenty percent off your first monthly
box when you sign up
think about that
twenty percent off your first monthly
box when you sign up at box of awesome
dot com and enter the code tim dillon at
checkout that's box of awesome.com code
tim dillon for 20 off your first box i
mean how cool is this
wallets
knives
coffee makers
a weekender a carry-all bag
socks
taco night reinvigorated
a a great thing for the a trail restore
a travel size creaming regimen for
looking great everywhere
things like this will come in your box
of awesome
it's really cool it's great to get
surprised with things that you need and
want
do you understand that yes
i need them and i want them
that knife looks really cool
does it
yeah it
does
you know you can do with that knife
you can hold it to the throat of a
salmon
you could
that's right
if the salmon's not doing something you
wanted to do
you can hold it right to the throat of a
salmon
if a salmon's getting mouthy with you
you put it right to the throat of that
salmon
and you cut that fish up
you can cut that fish up
you ever got a fish
i have
i'm speaking rhetorically rhetorical
question
box of awesome dot com enter the code
tim dillon at checkout that's box of
awesome dot go dot com
tim dillon for 20 off your first box
we read a real uh fun article about palm
beach um
all roads lead to mar-a-lago inside the
fury and fantasy of donald trump's
florida you've got oh you've got a fun
crew
down there i mean
let's separate this from ideology for a
minute i know the audience is incapable
of doing that
you know i i i don't understand it's
probably because they have nothing going
on in their lives that brings them any
enjoyment but
separating ideology for a minute it's
just a fun crew
roger stone tucker sean hannity ben
shapiro laura ingram ann coulter
brad parskal the trump campaign manager
who's now advising caitlyn jenner the
epicenter of the american conservative
movement has become florida it's become
this swamp of of um you know
goons and scoundrels and grifters and
just
all around fun people
tabloid culture tabloid culture the
birthplace of the the national enquirer
and matt drudge lives down there the
drudge report which i love and
conservatism was kept out of
these mainstream institutions for a long
time you know a lot of the major papers
in america
and uh
television networks
were cosmopolitan in the sense that they
were never hard left for sure they were
liberal they were decidedly liberal on a
lot of the key values that conservatives
find themselves on the other side of and
that's why
a lot of the conservative personalities
in media
are a bit flashier because they uh
they're rappers essentially they they
they
they talk [ __ ]
they're not getting published in
mainstream places right so they had to
take over alternative media talk radio
and the internet and people like rush
limbaugh and matt drudge and ann coulter
and they came
from outside
uh of this uh
system where you played these
respectability politics and these guys
like christopher ruddy who started
newsmax and they're all down there in
palm beach florida
and it it just seems like a lot of fun
it seems like a lot of fun and if you
read this vanity fair article like the
the waiter who's serving roger stone and
laura loomer
uh food
it goes like this so they're seated in a
private room a heavy set waiter comes in
an immigrant from yugoslavia named mario
who introduces himself as a die-hard
republican he's crestfallen he sees
laura loomer and
uh you know roger stone sitting there
and he goes unbelievable what they did
to us and loomer goes i know and the
waiter goes bunch of criminals and stone
oliver's tone goes not over yet
and then mario goes that's right i'm
hoping we're all hoping
so they're keeping that hope alive down
there in florida
it's like you know the song the
beginning of portlandia the dream of the
90s is alive in portland
that's what's going on and
the dream of q is alive and palm beach
you know
and it's just these people just kind of
dancing around eating steaks and
martinis at 3 p.m
thinking that trump's going to be
reinstalled as president somehow fat
mario the waiter laura loomer
and coulter who then at the end of the
article ann coulter and matt trudge go
we're leaving florida and we're not
telling anybody where we're going
and i guess they're leaving because uh
judge and i are both leaving florida and
we're not telling anyone where we're
going this time
um i guess because coulter had she's
fallen out of the trump camp she's
unhappy with trump but it's fun
florida's always kind of been a fun
place and and i remember when we snuck
into the breakers buffet yes
and there's something nice about florida
there's something distinctly american
about lying your way
into an all-you-can-eat mother's day
buffet without a mother
we had no mother we honored no one it
was just to sit there and feed ourselves
on shellfish and it was great and segura
was there but we didn't even see them
but that's uh that's florida for you
it's a fun article in vanity fair if you
read it and uh
the i mean the thing is
you know ben said i'd love to go to one
of these parties earlier
and you would and you wouldn't
because one thing i learned
um when i was debating people that were
to become people like this right a lot
of the kids that i was debating when i
was in college and even though i was at
a community college many of these people
were going on to four-year schools and
uh they were going to i think one of
them worked for mitt romney for a while
the thing about people who live sleep
eat and breathe politics
is that
they're boring
the thing about politics is
it obscures many of the truths of life
which are
truly
apolitical right the deep human truths
of life
which is what art tries to get to which
is why art sucks now because we're
fitting those truths or showcasing them
in a way that has to break down into
this political binary it's not natural
but
and i'm not saying artists are fun to be
around either don't don't mistake me but
the thing about people whose entire life
their entire existence the way they
interface with the world is all politics
is deeply unfulfilling it's deeply
unfulfilling
and many of them know that
um
because there is a
disconnect
between
what you're saying
and what's happening
and that's a chasm
meaning you're not really in the fight
to change things as much as you're in
the fight
to become famous or wealthy
and
you're really trying to establish
yourself
and then there's this movement of people
that you can kind of grab onto for a
minute and you could guide them or push
them
in a certain way but that's an unruly
mob of human beings that's just going to
go somewhere else or you got to keep
track of them keep hold of them it's not
easy
and you know
real change is very difficult and it's
not that glamorous and the people that
work to make real change like real
activists lawyers and doctors and people
that give up lucrative careers to then
go help people on the street and
actually help people get elected to
local uh government and change laws that
affect people's lives
that's very different than the pundit
class who's swilling
you know gin martinis at 3 a.m at the
breakers in palm beach and talking about
revolution and this is happening and
this is hap and none of it's really
happening that's the thing i mean it's
not really
happening and and the people that do
this kind of know that but they've given
themselves over to it and their entire
life is politics there's not much else
there
and
it's why i decided to get out you know i
thought i wanted to be in that world and
i said i don't want to be in the world i
don't have to have an idea or a thought
and go wait a minute
is this
is this something that my enemies would
say or is this something my allies would
say
and and
then what
i didn't want to have to put everything
through that prism
but if i did it does seem fun
to do it in in palm beach florida
with these lunatics they seem a lot more
fun
than the neoliberal hampton sat and the
brooklyn socialists said these people
seem a lot more fun if we're just gonna
go off fun
if we're just gonna go off fun
martinis with these lunatics
i mean
the true answer is none of the above but
if you had to
it might be here hurricane heading a
long island long island does very well
with hurricanes i remember after
hurricane sandy people were sitting out
on their lawn uh with rifles because
they were afraid of quote uh wandering
gangs of minorities
so long island really shines during
natural disasters
uh people were going around to rob each
other's houses
um on long island there were people
sitting in their driveways with weapons
and i'm not saying that there wasn't
some [ __ ] i'm sure there was this is
hurricane henry or henry
it is strengthening and is expected to
become a hurricane on saturday
i'm really wondering
uh how bad this is gonna be
now
you gotta remember that
strengthens to a category one that's
nothing that's nothing nothing
hurricane sandy
was the long island
it was the first time in a very long
time that long island had really gone
through
a natural
uh disaster
um
it destroyed
650 000 homes or damaged
it took years
to get
back on their feet these people
i knew long island was finally back
when insurance companies were calling
people and saying we overpaid you we
gave you too much money and you owe us
money and then people that i knew from
comedy comedians in long island that
didn't have jobs were working at those
call centers calling up these elderly
people who had finally just had a moment
of peace because their home had just
been finished after years and said hey
miss marino we overpaid you about 30 000
you owe us what you owe us money
the insurance company you better make
good
what's going on
ralph they're saying we owe the money
you better [ __ ] pay you old [ __ ]
so as soon as that started happening
again and
people in long island started leaning
into their character i knew that long
island was gonna be fine but i remember
i was living in new york city when
hurricane sandy happened and it damaged
uh where i grew up i mean it was
underwater the town i grew up in was
under water
it was really really bad
um
yeah this is uh photos from island park
uh during a hurricane sandy it was bad
people were without power
people there's boats in people's yards
um looters will be shot like that there
you go
that's beautiful
but it did it pushed people to the brink
and i'm
not you know i i did not experience it
right i was in manhattan i never lost
power i was living in midtown manhattan
some of manhattan lost power downtown
but now where i lived and hurricane
sandy was it was real character building
from long island it really was long
island used to be a racist place
after hurricane sandy
long island was what used to be a place
where people like very paranoid
about different races now after
hurricane sandy it really
became a beautiful place
where different types of people
understood and respected each other
but
before that can you believe it was not
that
um
and long island uh it was tough and i
remember talking to friends
um and of course people were you know
people used hurricane sandy for years
after
as an excuse for one of their lives
it's we will be covered too
you know you will
the biggest losers in your life
and they're already doing it but they'll
do it more
we'll go i had so much going on
coven
i was about to do it
do what
everything covered
and that's what hurricane sandy was
people like i was still i was oh my god
hurricane sandy can't and it [ __ ] me
for years
yes
i couldn't get a job or go to school or
anything i just had to sit in water for
years
and drink
i just had to sit in in disgusting water
and drink for seven years after
hurricane sandy and that's what's gonna
happen with covet too on the other side
of kovid people are gonna go yeah you
know i was i was gonna go to college
or i was gonna get that job i was gonna
move that's gonna be the big one i was
gonna leave
but i because of covid
i couldn't do it and some of those
people will be correct just like some of
the people in long island were being
genuine when they said that this [ __ ]
up their plans but then there will be
the vast majority of people that are uh
or maybe not the vast majority but far
too many people that are just lying
about this and you're gonna turn around
it'll be like it'll be like 20 26
and you'll go so wait a minute
run this back again
you drop you didn't go to college in
because of the coronavirus
explain this
and then they'll have to jump through
hoops and explain it and say like oh
well actually what happened was my
mother's friend died of coven and we
took in her cat
and that
was more of a burden than we had
imagined and then i thought i had it but
i never did and then
we couldn't pay the bills because my
uncle had a bar and my boyfriend got in
a bar fight with a guy who may have had
covert and that was why he was crazy and
my boyfriend split his head open in the
parking lot and we had to pay for my
boyfriend to get out of jail and then go
to trial and then he did six months and
six months well he can't work and how
are we gonna feed this cat from that
lady who died of covet and you see what
i mean covet
you go what
you see
because that's people hurricane sandy
they'll be my car
was destroyed in hurricane sandy and
then i got another car and it was
repossessed uh and it was taken by the
state because uh they said i was drunk
but i wasn't and you go
does this really have to do with the
hurricane
can you draw a straight line
from the hurricane to where you are now
draw a straight line from coven to where
you are now many people will be able to
they'll be like i went in i had 19
strokes and then you go got it right
hey
got it
and those people are gonna barely be
able to talk
we get it
but
then there's going to be the people who
are going to get very creative
about this period of time
and i and i said before i said on the
patreon episode
uh how
excited i am for
whatever the next phase of life is
whatever the next phase of culture is
because we need it
people are psychologically coming apart
uh the news is uh uh circular
we've all had enough
there's nothing
that we haven't talked about 19 times
you know
um
it would be like imagine if hurricane
sandy kept happening
like imagine if hurricane sandy just
kept battering
like you would build the house halfway
back and then
gale force winds again
floods again
it would be crazy
if that kept happening like hurricane
katrina just happened the next year
[Music]
just again they're like it's another
surge
it's hurricane katrina delta variant and
it just
wouldn't stop magic spoon cereal is the
best it is so good it's got zero grams
of sugar 13 14 grams of protein only
four net grams of carbs in each serving
it's keto friendly gluten free grain
free soy free low carb you can build
your own box or get a variety pack with
available flavors like cocoa fruity
frosted peanut butter blueberry and
cinnamon magic spoon is bringing back
two super popular flavors cookies and
cream and maple waffle permanently when
these flavors were first introduced for
a limited time they sold out extremely
quickly let your listeners oh no which
i'm doing now that they should [ __ ]
get these
magicspoon.com tim dillon to grab your
delicious cereal today many of you want
to enjoy
sugar
cereal that doesn't have sugar and how
does that happen well magic spoon uses
very
high quality sweeteners like monk fruit
it's great
magicspoon.com tim dillon if they're so
confident in their product it's backed
by 100 happiness guarantee so if you
don't like it for any reason they'll
refund your money no question to ask
they're so confident in their product
it's back with 100 happiness guarantee
so listen to that they really want you
to have this cereal
remember get your next delicious bowl of
guilt-free cereal
at
magicspoon.com tim dillon and use the
code tim dillon to save five dollars off
thank you magic spoon for sponsoring
this episode
raycon earbuds i love them we're all
gonna lose
uh our uh you know our name brand
headphones so we go to raycon why
because ray pot raycon starts at half
the price of other premium audio brands
but they sound just as good
they come with a 45-day happiness
guarantee so you really can't lose give
them a try you'll see what i mean it's
great to have a backup pair of
headphones earbuds
okay
i love them on a plane train whatever
you want to do running jogging in the
gym
talking to friends and family just slip
one in maybe you get one that's
say it's a hearing aid but it's not you
don't have to listen to them ray khan is
super
super easy
six hours of playing time every 32 hour
battery life you can listen to what you
want when you want forever
you got to create your own soundtrack in
life
by popping it what would your soundtrack
be
my soundtrack for my life yes hmm
maybe a soundtrack to a film like maybe
uh maybe no country for old men you know
what i think it would be
just wind blowing through a window
raycon
dot com slash tim
buy raycon dot com slash tim to save 15
percent on ray cons
you get great
earbuds they're perfect
and and they're they cost a lot less
you want to save your money folks
and this is a great way to do it raycon
buy raycon.com
just say 15
on ray cons
thank you for supporting the show ray
khan
this is great larry david screamed at
alan dershowitz at a grocery store
because he's mad that he's friends with
donald trump
or that he's in the trump team
i saw you with your arm around mike
pompeo it's disgusting dershowitz goes
he's my former student at harvard law i
greet all of my former students that way
i can't greet my former students david
it's disgusting your whole enclave it's
disgusting you're disgusting
then larry walks away allen takes off
his t-shirt to reveal another t-shirt
that says it's the constitution stupid
and then dershowitz drove off in an old
dirty volvo i love by the way that it
wasn't that he's been accused multiple
times of rape
by underage people
it's that he's like a republican
that's really if you want to talk about
hollywood that's the perfect
encapsulation of hollywood you know
it'd be like if jeffrey epstein was
found out that he was alive and larry
david bumped into him in martha's
vineyard he'd be like i can't believe
you were such good friends with trump i
never knew that
by the way dershowitz uh has been
accused by this uh virginia giuffray
jeffrey yeah virginia guthrie of of
molesting her right multiple times yeah
uh seven times seven times between the
ages of 16 and 19. that's too much using
some of the same language that he had
employed to describe epson's victims a
decade earlier this is what dershowitz
called this woman this is how you know
she's telling the truth he called her a
serial liar a prostitute and a bad
mother
i mean
that sounds a bit personal
for someone you didn't rape
dirsh
can you believe that
like if somebody accused you of rape
wouldn't your first question be like
what who how huh
but he's like she's a liar prostitute
and a bad mother it's like well it
sounds like you're protesting a little
bit too much
in fact i think that you know this woman
quite well and you may have done the
wrong thing to her
then he said who could not be believed
quote against somebody with an unscathed
reputation like me does he have an
unscathed reputation i don't know about
that
he insisted that guffrey had quote made
the whole thing up out of whole cloth in
search of quote a big payday
when a tv reporter in miami questioned
his characterization of guthrie a sex
abuse victim as quote a prostitute there
schwitz replied she made her own
decisions in life
he's basically admitting he [ __ ] her
but he's saying she's a prostitute who
cares she made her own decisions even
though she was underage
yeah
so it was just very interesting larry
david kind of like bumped into him in
martha's vineyard and was like hey
i cannot believe that you're a
republican
forget the friendship with jeffrey
epstein
forget the multiple accusations of of
child rape
when two people when he but when when a
hollywood person and i love larry's
brilliant comedian but it's just funny
it's like you know you are in a little
bit of a bubble unless there's more to
this which we didn't hear where he's and
maybe that's part of why he's grossed
out by dirsh but like you know you're in
a little bit of a bubble when somebody
walk you bump into
uh an accused child rapist on martha's
vineyard and your biggest problem with
them is that they're friends with the
trump team
that seems odd
larry's a knee jerk radical dershowitz
called page six he takes his politics
from hollywood he doesn't read a lot he
doesn't think a lot
it's typical of what happens now on the
vineyard
says dirsh people who won't talk to each
other if they don't agree on their
politics
well what about the child rape
i love this he goes
it's the price of principal
this guy
is a uh he's been involved in some very
uh very nefarious dealings
and he's probably done some horrible
things
and uh
what's funny now is that he relishes
this every time somebody yells at him
about being in the trump circle it's
it's it's a
it helps him because what they're not
yelling at him about is uh the
incredible accusations of child rape
that he's also
had a
large part of
so like every interview he does he's
like i'm just they get mad at me because
i believe in the constitution it's like
that's not
alan
you know that's not it
i just watch by the way the people
versus o.j simpson again because it's on
netflix it's great and he's in that not
him but an actor
um
this is funny that was a great go back
to that uh photo
it's uh the noted lawyer's long
controversial career jeffrey epstein o.j
simpson
mike tyson uh
is that limbaugh i believe so yeah might
be limbot's trump
i don't know this is a good article
alan dershowitz the article is devil's
advocate i mean he's an amazing lawyer
right i mean we can't take that away
from you sure he's a great lawyer
he'll be representing the taliban
soon
the taliban will have alan dershowitz
and he'll go people are mad because i
represented the taliban
that's why they're angry he's going to
keep doing controversial things to take
the heat off the whole epstein thing
if he was smart right now he'd be in
afghanistan
defending the taliban
so that people
you know
[Music]
uh forget that he's been accused
and where is jizz lane maxwell's trial
just to check in on that piece of news
see what's going on
where is she what's going on with jesus
how is this woman
yeah they're trying to they're trying to
get prince andrew yeah trying
the royal family may just hang him out
to dry huh
i didn't think that was gonna happen but
it's very possible the royal family saw
andrew you know what
we don't like you that much anyway
you're sort of odd you blink a lot you
don't sweat
strange
so the royal family
prosecutors asked judge to withhold the
names of just lane maxwell's uncharged
co-conspirators from her
meaning
go down here this is interesting federal
prosecutors urged a judge not to force
them to provide
chizlane maxwell a complete list of her
uncharged co-conspirators urging that
those that
disclosure risks quote harm to the
government from restricting its proof at
trial
you wonder if she's gonna try to have
him whacked
oh yeah yeah although it's not required
to do so the government can state that
as of the date of this letter and
although the government may change its
view as it prepares for trial it
currently intends to introduce
co-conspirator statements at trial from
only two individuals okay
maxwell asked to learn their identities
earlier as one of the categories of
information her defense team requested
to avoid a trial by ambush she wants to
know she goes i have a right to know
who's diming on me in open court
i have a right to know so that those
people can get threatened
it's what's going on
she goes i should know who they are
there is accordingly no significant risk
that the defense will be surprised at
trial by a profound
profusion of co-conspirators in their
statements even if the government
identifies statements for use at trial
from additional co-conspirators the
letter says this court has twice
concluded
that no bill of particulars is warranted
because the defendant has adequate
information to prepare for trial
um
and avoid unfair surprise
julie k brown at the miami herald whose
reporting has been widely credited with
sparking epstein and maxwell's
prosecutions alpine the transparency has
been getting worse on the dockets her
public records battles in court led to
the release of thousands of pages which
included the names of prominent men
allegedly implicated in epstein's
conspiracy despite that flood of
documents courts remain under pressure
to keep more files under wraps and
heavily redacted
so it'll be interesting to see which um
how they go so push to november now was
july push to november right in the
height
of the uh the delta storm right yeah
well it'll be interesting i'm gonna say
that maxwell gets
like
look at this jizzlane maxwell reportedly
sells house where alleged sex crimes
occur
she's offloaded her now notorious london
home
2.5 mil
the socialite acts of late pedophile
jeffrey epstein had put her muse house
in the super exclusive belgravia
neighborhood
on the market for 2.7 million
her spokesman uh first confirmed earlier
this year was finally bought by a
property developer
for around 2.42 million the house has
long played a central role in her sex
ring scandal
yeah
and this is where uh prince andrew was
photographed hugging his accuser
when she was just 17.
well
she dumped some real estate she's
she needs money like everything else
like everybody else she needs money and
uh
i'm sure
meanwhile max what would be sad about
the sale for london quote refuge because
it held happy memories her spokesman
told the mail
what's great is that these people forget
like what they're on trial for
and they have to pretend that none of
it's real
so they have to like release statements
like that
well it was a refuge darling and there
was many happy memories there
so many happy memories that
i just will miss it i'll miss sipping
tea in the yard and
so many happy memories of drugged up
children running around
you know prince andrew chasing girls
through the through the hall just
chasing them through the corridor
um
yeah she's still in brooklyn
well
our tour rolls on folks uh uh you know
assuming that i don't collapse from
exhaustion i'm getting stronger every
day i did uh 20 minutes last night in
um
austin texas so we're at the chicago
improv in schaumburg everyone's like oh
it's no chicago it's the suburbs hey man
that's where the seats are right
i'm already doing 10 [ __ ] shows
uh i i which i shouldn't even be doing
i you know i'm not going to be doing 30
[ __ ] shows it's
i need a bigger room so schaumburg
improv there are some tickets left
because we've opened all of these up i
believe
at full cap
some of them say they're sold out i
don't know but let's see but it might be
tickets
try to figure it out
september 9th corpus christi texas
mesquite street comedy
okay
september 23rd
through the 25th baltimore maryland
october 7th
through the 9th milwaukee wisconsin
uh
wednesday october 20th
through the 21st is spokane washington
um and then there's a theater run that
we're announcing too the beacon theater
thursday november 11th in new york
that's going to be big
um and of course our our dates in san
diego that got rescheduled because of
coven
um
which i said family emergency but i knew
i knew i probably had coven so i said it
was a family emergency and then i
finally got the test back and they're
like it's kovan
um
but i was like i can't go because he was
saying negative but i'm like there's no
way
um san diego in december but the beacon
theater is gonna be the big one in new
york stand up live podcast um it's
really cool
um
we've moved a lot of tickets already and
uh we're very excited about it but all
right listen let me go drink some
[ __ ] water with lime
to get my throat uh going patreon.com
for the bonus episodes uh support our
the products um that we sell on the show
it helps support us uh we appreciate you
guys buying live tickets and then the
merch will drop some new merch in
december around the holidays we'll give
you ample time
for that we're not always trying to
shove merch down your throat fake
business was awesome people
uh are happy with that seemingly and uh
you know we're gonna try to do something
a little different
in
um
december something smaller maybe one or
two items
in december for those people that didn't
grab the fake business stuff or want
some other stuff the quality of the last
merge drop was really high
uh the the hoodies and
everything like that there's some really
cool stuff there and we're working on
something
that will have the same quality
uh perhaps we can bring down the price
that's our hope in december because i
know people going to be buying a lot of
different things
you know socks from cody co or whatever
so we just want to make sure that
everybody can we love cody buy
everything from him but
uh we know you're spreading yourself out
you know
um so we're gonna try to do something
that is
uh
cost effective
um and i do wanna go to
afghanistan to do a benefit
for the the women's foundation
the reason i'm not
is because i i i get it
you know
and i don't want to be left on a tarmac
in
kabul because that's
you got to really assess why you're
doing what you're doing you have to
really truly uh because everybody who
does charity real charity
should be prepared to be left on the
tarmac in kabul
it shouldn't just be
some dinner party in the hamptons you
should actually
have to put your money where your mouth
is and and go to kabul
and
it's not the worst thing listen a lot of
those women that went over there man
whoever
this will be a very interesting part of
your life
i truly believe that
i believe it will be an interesting uh
part of your life and i don't think that
you should necessarily look at it as
something negative
i think you should look at it as a as a
positive development you know
because
you know
this is the way it is now
and
you know
that's the thing like
you know the taliban
is the real version of the fascism that
you people
constantly moan about being here
you know our fascists are inept they're
incapable they're drinking martinis in
uh
florida they can't oppress you that much
although they'd love to perhaps
um
but the taliban can
they like
have a real singular focus
on
creating a society that is sufficiently
religious
and uh they're gonna do that and um
i hope everyone gets out i hope all the
translators get out i hope all the
people that
uh were there to do charity get out but
that seems unrealistic
right now because you trusted the united
states
and you went to do a good thing but
sometimes
the price of doing a good thing is
seeing it through
and now you're gonna have to see it
through
i would suggest go the other way if you
were there to work for a woman's charity
right now
go hard the other way i'm talking burka
start whipping women in the street
you're gonna need to kind of
you are going to need
to
figure out how to ingratiate yourself
with the leadership so if you were a
translator and you could delete your
history so they don't know who you are
you got to be the behander
wouldn't that be great if you went over
to afghanistan to help and now you're
the behander
you're just be handing thieves or people
that maybe aren't thieves
and you go you know i came over here i
was working uh
i was working with a uh you know what
teach afghani children uh about
capitalism
uh thing and we were gonna have gary vee
come over and do a talk it was great we
came over with a uh
you know teach afghanis about investment
teach afghans about investment um and we
were teaching uh students how to be uh
hustlers and grinders
and start their own energy drink company
but
that all went bad i couldn't get out and
now i'm the behander
and i just i just
i just lob people's hands off and i
throw them in a bucket
you know
it's a different hustle
it's a different grind but ultimately
it's the same thing right is it life
simple can you just enjoy the simplicity
of life i say this to all the women
there now that we're americans or
whatever and all the people that are
trapped can you just enjoy a simplified
life maybe you don't need starbucks
just enjoy a simplified life
enjoy the simple pleasures of
theocratic fascism the real kind
yes it's gonna suck for a little bit but
adjustments are tough change is never
easy it's never easy
i feel like them standing on the tarmac
at [ __ ] what's this airport called oh
in kabul no in austin oh austin
bergstrom yeah standing on the tarmac at
austin bergstrom waiting to leave i
which i'm leaving in a few months i have
a
similar feeling
a similar feeling i'm one of the last
ones out i'm going to be
one of the last ones out
and as i look out at the plane and i see
people falling off it and i see just
people running around with burqas eating
brisket
performing at comedy clubs that aren't
comedy clubs you know as i look at all
those damned doomed people just running
through the drunken melee
you know i'm gonna say to myself we
never
should have invaded
we never
places have cultures
and those cultures matter and they're
resilient and the austin they're gonna
take it back they're gonna take it back
from joe rogan and elon musk those
drunken savage animals those complete
failures those thoughtless nothings are
going to come back and it may take them
20 years i imagine it'll take them a lot
less than that they're gonna float on
their rafts and that beer piss lake they
all like and they're gonna float right
to shore and they're gonna waddle off
all coved up and brown recluse spit and
they're gonna just walk in all drunk
full of taco farts and they're gonna go
my friend's got a show tonight he's in a
bed
and you're gonna look at these brainless
zombies and go you know what this place
is theirs
it's theirs it's not the tech people and
it's not joe's and it's not elon's it's
none of that
it is for those brainless
zombies we never
should have invaded but now we can make
it right we can get out and let them do
what they're gonna do because the austin
taliban will be back
and better than ever